blamed for the crime viewed with
suspicion
and told to hush it up many women who
experience sexual assault in pakistan
say this is what they face but amidst
this victim shaming the country's leader
prime minister imran khan has gone on
television and appeared
to do the same last month he told an
interviewer
i quote if a woman is wearing very few
clothes it will have an
impact on the man unless they are robots
uncaught
and in april during a live chat
broadcast on state television khan
urged women to wear a veil to avoid
sexual assault
saying it is so that there is no
temptation
in society
activists say his comments reinforce
common public perceptions
that women invite their assaults and
they say that attitude
needs to change
uma raja is getting ready to go out
but choosing what to wear in pakistan is
a fraught decision
women can be judged harshly for how they
dress in the conservative country
she'd like to just put on what she wants
and be done with it
i always say that there is nothing that
makes me more happy
than seeing women owning who they are
and kind of you know breaking
stereotypes and putting a full stop
there because
if one woman decides to do that you know
that changes the fate of entire
generation generation of women who are
still
fighting for basic rights just recently
an interview with prime minister imran
khan unleashed fresh
protests he said that wearing a veil
would stop
men from being drawn into temptation
implying women were at fault for sexual
violence
his remarks caused uproar amongst rights
activists
i think here he has discriminated
and he put all the blame and burden
over women address that that was not
fair he should have
uh addressed to men as well so i think
that was totally unfair with women of
pakistan many women in pakistan have
already experienced sexual violence
including uma when she was six her
parents left her alone with a male
friend of the family
she trusted him but he abused that trust
uma wants to convince other women to
speak openly about sexual violence
she says it's the only way to change
prevailing attitudes that blame victims
for sexual assaults rather than
perpetrators
when we are a collective voice will make
a difference you know we don't need
to be ashamed that it happened to us the
burden of proof
the shame lies with the ones who do that
so this is something i think protests
are making a huge difference in pakistan
but fundamental change may be elusive
until those in power
get behind their cause
and for more on this i'm joined by binis
javed from dw asia
binish women's groups are outraged over
imran khan's
recent comments is imran khan
misogynistic
hi pradesh imran ha does continue to
disappoint pakistani women he has
repeatedly given statements
that women rights campaigners say
undermine the gravity
of sexual crimes against pakistani women
they say they are appalled
by his naive approach to a very complex
problem
and blaming women and their clothing for
heinous crimes like rape
is a humiliation to all those who have
suffered they also say that publicly
saying
that men cannot control their temptation
unless they are robots
these kind of statements give validation
and encouragement to men
that they can go and harass anyone they
want as long as they think that she's
not properly
dressed i'm wondering if this approach
to women's
issues offers him any political
advantage
yes absolutely so during his election
campaign
and also as a prime minister all his
views on
a religion on women's place in the
society
on western values all pander to
far right individuals and conservatives
in the country
and if you speak to his supporters or
government ministers
they say that he's not saying anything
that's incorrect he actually reflects
uh the mindset of pakistani society so
it seems that his supporters
subscribe to a very patriarchal and
traditional
view of pakistan and they don't
understand or are insensitive
to the changing gender roles in the
society um
and i think they don't understand that
pakistan in society is slowly
but struggling to become more liberal
and dynamic
binish you have grown up in pakistan
spent a lot of time over there i wonder
how this
pandering to the conservative elements
of pakistani society
impacts daily life for a woman in
pakistan
um so yeah i have grown up in pakistan
and i tell you that
i was brought up very differently from
uh the way my brothers were brought up
women from their childhood are taught to
behave a certain way they are taught
that they need
protection um that they are submissive
um they have to
uh behave a certain way dress up a
certain way
um and i think um slowly and gradually
these beliefs and these concepts are
changing women
are aspiring to have more dominant
position in a society they are aspiring
to have
their voices recognized that kind of
change
still seems unacceptable to
conservatives in the society
and imran khan does not want to lose the
support of those conservatives
peninsula thanks so much for speaking to
us today
thank you in neighboring india misogyny
has taken an ugly unsettling turn
recently a little over 80 muslim women
discovered they had been put up for sale
on a newly created app by unknown people
the app
called sully deals offered the women up
as deals of the day using photographs
from their social media profiles
this is a screenshot shared on twitter
by one of the women targeted
sully is a slur directed against muslim
women
in india the app was hosted on github an
open source hosting platform
and was ultimately taken down after
numerous complaints now one of those who
was targeted and who later also filed
the police complaint
is commercial pilot hana mosin akan who
joins me now
hannah welcome and thanks so much for
joining us today i'd just like to begin
by asking you
how you are doing since you became aware
you had been targeted in this way
thank you so much for having me um how
i'm doing i'm
i'm okay um i have this i keep repeating
here
everywhere that i have this rage that is
uh
constant this anger which is constant so
i've compartmentalized it i
i am doing my work and i am doing other
things but i also this this underlying
anger and you know rage just doesn't go
away so
other than that i'm doing okay now
why do you think you and other muslim
women
were targeted in this way
well um so interestingly uh
you know i am not a political account i
don't write politics um you know there's
nothing that i
uh fight against i don't say bad things
about people online because of the work
that i'm in
um and i was still targeted so
that is you know like it's completely
transparent why that happened it's
because i was a muslim woman who had a
voice
um all the women who were targeted are
all educated women
they're with women who you know have a
presence on social media when they talk
people listen
so that is the reason that we were
targeted in the first place because we
were muslim women who were talking who
were who had a conversation going who
people listened to we didn't you know
fit into their
narrative of this muslim woman that fake
narrative that they want everyone just
to to believe that we are muslim women
are oppressed
and somehow um you know don't have
rights which is absolutely incorrect you
know you'll be right here in front of
you and
saying that this is incorrect which is
why i think all of us were targeted
is this something that's particularly uh
far worse for muslim women given the
fact
that women in general in india our
uh educated women particularly are
targets on social media
absolutely it's like fighting in on
every front
you know uh or women as you said there's
there's this patriarchal you know
society that
that surrounds us we have to fight so
much
and work so hard to do what we're doing
to get where we are
um you know fight mindsets fight uh
people who are
uh saying that we cannot do what we want
to do uh people telling us how to walk
what to wear how what to eat etc etc and
you still make it
so you are already fighting with so many
elements and then
along comes these the hate um you know
gangs and
they are auctioning us online so just
it's just like it feels as if you know
you're just fighting
so many different uh you know upfronts
and that i think is absolutely unfair
for any human being in the world
and especially women in india uh we are
already fighting so many things and
you add this to us also so you
so we we are strong we we are strong
enough to retaliate but
do we need to be like this do we need to
be this way
do you think the targeting of muslim
women in particular has become more
pronounced
in recent years and if so why
see absolutely i think uh like you know
um
i don't i like to talk about how at in
ancient times
women were all until date women are
supposed to be the soft target of a
community
so community that has already been
targeted on different levels
lynching is being become commonplace all
of that's already
you know so normal here no it's become
normalized
now you come to that um you know
so so they think that we are the soft
targets now you've also filed a police
complaint
in this matter how hopeful are you that
the police will actually act
so uh i am i i have been
treated very nicely by the police i have
uh
you know uh i i'm not so
like i did not get any negative vibes
there i was treated very nicely they
call
they're calling me again um you know all
the time they're they're
they're asking me for any update i'm
asking them for updates so they've been
very decent
um you know so far and i and delhi
police actually made an fir without
me anyone else doing an fire in delhi
yet
um and the women's commission has been
has spoken about it without
uh you know uh it was an fir in noida
that happened and you know
so so i am pretty hopeful that they
might come you know uh they might
get to the bottom of this i am pretty
hopeful
hannah mossy and can't we leave it there
for the time being but thank you so much
for joining us today
thank you so much thank you